[Musique]
bonjour yves camdeborde bonjour merci
nous accorder cet entretien leur essor
cuisinier et patrons de plusieurs
restaurants à paris et à bordeaux depuis
le 15 juin ça y est les restaurants
ouverts en ile-de-france et plus
seulement en terrasse dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes aujourd'hui est ce
que vous êtes soulagés ou est-ce que
vous êtes encore très inquiets mais
disons que je suis retrouvé le sourire
et ça c'est quand même important dans la
vie d'avoir le sourire parce que voilà
on a retrouvé de notre jouer notre
métier de cuisinier restaurateurs
hôteliers et donc ça c'est des primes au
diable ça nous a redonné je dirais de de
la pêche et de la bonne humeur mais
après c'est vrai qu'on ait une
inquiétude sur les sur les mois à venir
racontez nous un peu ce que vous avez
traversé avec ses longs mois de
fermeture c'était très violent c'était
très violent on a appris à 21 peu comme
tout le monde que quatre heures après il
fallait il fallait arrêter nos activités
après le gouvernement a mis en place au
delà des accompagnements qui nous ont
été bénéfiques ils ont nous ont permis
de survivre on est des pertes
financières qui est colossal et
aujourd'hui bon nombre de collègues et
moi même nous entraînant des difficultés
financières qui nous font peur parce
qu'on se dit si le loi le travail ne
reprend pas sur le rythme générique
assez conséquent là si on reste comme on
est en ce moment à tourner entre 25 et
40% de notre capacité ça peut pas durer
on sent qu'il ya encore un peu de
sidération après après ces mois là il ya
quand même pas mal d aide sur la table
évidemment le choix du chômage partiel
le prêt garanti par l'état qu'est ce que
vous voulez aujourd'hui vous aimeriez
que l'état vous dise on éprouve tout je
vais vous dire moi d un premier temps
voilà moi je pense que le prêt et voilà
ça reste près quand même 16 0% euro
resteront 100 euros alors c'est une
charge financière qu'on va avoir sur le
sur le long terme commencent à la limite
je veux vous dire si on l'a accepté
parce qu'on est capables si ça
refonctionne de l'assumer moix qui sont
très difficiles si voilà déjà c'est la
matière première qu on a perdu parce que
personne n'a pas trop mais fermé samedi
soir alors que le week-end soit paris
sur des gros week-end moi j'ai quand
même perdu plus de 30000 euros de
matières premières et après le le coût
des loyers le coût des loyers est
colossal en à paris on sait tous que les
boys par exemple très élevé alors quand
ça fonctionne mais ça rentre dans le
cahier des charges financiers donc ça
passe mais là on a eu pendant trois mois
à la sortie de l'argent de loyer sans
aucune rentrée vous ai entendu dire à la
télévision on creuse notre tombe c'est à
ce point là on crie on creuse octobre
financière c'est comme quand vous n'êtes
pas de rentrées d'argent mais c'est très
simple c'est mathématique pour raser pas
de rentrées d'argent avec les sortez
sortez des sorties elles vont donner ça
se vide saïd ce que vous voudriez des
référents qui vont rester sur le carreau
oui beaucoup énormément énormément qu'il
aurait pu être un grand défi des à moins
à moins faux apprenons le rêve tous
c'est que tout reparte comme avant c'est
la fréquentation l'autorisent à paris la
consommation la ola l'algérie on va
passer des mauvais moments mais à ça va
être son site rien que ça peut durer une
année un an et demi deux ans pour se
remettre à flot mais on va y arriver
tandis que si on retrouve pas rapidement
suffisamment de potentiel client pour
tous nous nous retrouvions le rythme de
travail nos entreprises c'est sûr qu'il
ya énormément d'entreprises qui vont
aller dans un mur et qu'ils vont déposer
le bilan philippe etchebest qui va
jusqu'à dire 30% devant vous fermez là
pour philippe des 30% mais je pense
qu'il est il est peut être en dessous de
la vérité il est en dessous de la vérité
la restauration est un domaine très
particulier c'est un domaine on gère du
chiffre d'affaires mais avec une
rentabilité qui est très petit ce conte
ce qu'on dit entre nous alors on vit sur
la bête revit sur un le film de la bête
et aujourd'hui on est le fils comme une
âme en dessous donc on est on est tous
arrivé à une situation désastreuse c'est
en semant parlant dans celle de la
solidarité entre chefs est ce que vous
vous êtes serrer les coudes dans cette
épreuve oui on sait série lego serrer
les coudes bien eu beaucoup de voix de
regroupement de chef et d'en partager
entre nous mais après la difficulté
c'est que chaque entreprise a une
problématique différente même si on a
tous la même réflexion c'est y arriver
sans sortir souvent les emplois là
souvent aussi nos fournisseurs faut pas
qu'on les oublie mais après entre moi et
m'a présenté cinq établissements dont
heure où j'ai eu la chance d'acheter les
murs donc cela il n'y a pas de problème
étant donné que j'ai pas être sorties
d'argent tu geler le crédit ça a été
déplacée de six mois donc c'est un peu
zappé restent encore fermés moi je gagne
pas d'argent mais ça allait vite c'est
pas le plus important mais elle joue
pour un club plus grand problème ce sont
les loyers les loyers sur ce problème
alors aujourd'hui on se bat et les
assurances qui n'ont pas joué le jeu à
part une ou deux qui a quand même
quelques amis un peu la main à la poche
on leur demande voilà une perte
d'exploitation qui va nous permettre
voilà de combler ce déficit qu'on a
creusé mais il ya une logique je le dis
je le redis votre appartement vous loger
quand vous êtes en location je vous dis
vous sortez dans la rue madame vous
n'aurez plus à vous dormez dans la rue
vous allez continuer à payer votre
appartement
est là peut-être qu'il ya un effort à
faire de notre côté à nous les bailleurs
un effort à faire aussi et je dirais que
l'état français ait un effort à faire
peut-être à trois on a trouvé une
solution en disant c'est un cas
exceptionnel le président dadis est une
guerre donc il ya des dommages
collatéraux au moins parce qu'on peut
pas les partager j'ai trouvé une sorte
de système pérenniser entre l'état les
assureurs est une sorte de fonds
solidarité avec les réparateurs et moi
je pense que je pense qu'on peut y
arriver alors on peut y arriver parce
que l'intérêt général c'est quoi c'est
que paris redevienne paris que la france
redevienne en france la connais pas des
gens qui sont amoureuses des gens qui
soient et gris c'est le pire ce taux
dans nos métiers où on est là pour
donner du bonheur à tout donner du
plaisir donc il faut que
psychologiquement on sort d'un état
comme ça alors il ya eu de la souffrance
dans cette période il y aussi de la
résilience on a vu certains chefs faire
du de la livraison du prêt-à-porter
culinaire c'est votre cas vous êtes
retourné aux fourneaux pendant le
confinement alors personnellement non je
ne l'ait pas fait mais c'est ça qu'est
la magique dans mon métier c'est que au
delà de l'imagination les chefs cuyeu
les grands maîtres d'hôtel on imagine de
l'imagination et ils ont pas trouvé
d'autre solution pour espérer de rester
viable financièrement parlant et aussi
de trouver une activité intellectuelle
qui leur a fait penser aussi à autre
chose et peut-être que naples a
développé à une nouvelle mode de
restauration peut-être c'est aussi
intéressant dans les mois à venir on
verra ce qui va en rester mais moi je
crois qu'on va on va mettre des
structures en place spécifique pour ce
genre de travail c'est-à-dire cuisinons
dans nos restaurants et en faisant en
faisant du traiteur emmenons les plats
directement sur la table des clients
mais chez eux et c'est très possible
convoi y avait deux bientôt des
établissements qui n'auront plus à ce
qu'on peut appeler le clean fantôme rien
ne remplace le contact physique dans un
restaurent moi j'ai fait ce métier là
que pour ça parce que quand j'allais au
restaurant quand j'étais petit mes
parents ils font de convivialité de
partage des changes avec les gens et
c'est vrai que le le traiteur et et tout
ce qu'on a vu se développer c'est pas ma
philosophie j'ai du mal à le faire et je
sais pertinement dans la vie quand on a
du mal à faire quelque chose faut pas le
faire parce qu'on ne sait pas bien vous
êtes un peu l'un des inventeurs du
bistrot gastro de la bistronomie en même
temps quand on est en temps de crise
économique est-ce qu'on peut manger
comme on va dans certains très grands
étoilés pour un menu à 300 euros est ce
que ça doit changer ça après la crise
est ce que il faut aller vers des
assiettes
extraordinaire mais plus abordable j'ai
envie de vous dire il en faut pour tout
le monde moi je veux pas rentrer dans ce
discours là parce que je pense que
il faut qu'il ya un rapport qualité prix
quel que soit le prix
la vraie question est là si vous mangez
un menu à 350 euros à 400 euros que vous
sortir de là et vous disiez jamais pour
mon argent parce que c'est quand même de
la magie c'est quand même de la magie
des grands des grandes mais les grandes
maisons l'a6 et des lieux où on se
permet des prestations et des techniques
de cuisine exceptionnelle qui coûte
beaucoup d'argent parce qu'il faut
savoir que bien souvent ces maisons là
c'est pas ces maisons lac bien les plus
d'argent parce qu'ils ont des frais
fixes qui sont colossaux par rapport à
la prestation du fonds et les français
alors les français pendant leur
confinement ils ont cuisiné
énormément cuisine et l'alimentation
c'est dans l'un des rares secteurs en
bonne santé pendant cette crise
économique on a acheté des bons produits
la qualité et la provenance les circuits
courts tout ça c'est en train de devenir
des exigences de plus en plus partagé on
est en train de vivre un tournant à
votre avis je pense que le tournant par
rapport la cuisine quotidienne avait été
pris cas mais depuis quelques années on
voyait comme les gens de plus en plus
intéressés et surtout on le voit point
de vue architecture de maisons ou
d'appartements avant la cuisine est
toujours la pièce du fond fermé
maintenant la chine est toujours c'est
le centre si bien souvent dans le salon
elle est ouverte les présentes donc je
pense qu'on avait déjà revalorisé on
s'est rendu compte que c'était important
mais si ça pouvait rester dans l'esprit
des gens de comprendre enfin que cuisine
et ça peut être simple c'est parce qu'on
n'est pas obligé de compliquer pour
cuisiner et surtout que c'est sans doute
le premier médicament
qu'on ne vous comprend le bien manger si
on mange bien qu'on boit bien c'est bon
pour la santé et ça c'est la chose la
plus important et on a revu aussi la
table familiale comme les tendances les
faits les familles dispersées ou les les
enfants qui s'en voit que je dois de se
retrouver autour d'une table basse à
maria mes enfants de se dire c'est
chouette kamen natale le fait maison
justement et l'après match énorme elle
n'est pas grosse importante c'est à dire
c'est à dire tout ce qui est produits
préparés toxiques voilà faute de cash
les paquets de cigarettes aux marques
fumer tue tout ce qui est plat préparé
transformé on pourrait marquer manger
tue et on est prise de conscience là
avec la crise sanitaire sur le fait
maison le bien manger on a sonné une
prise de conscience qui réel je pense
que déjà le citoyen et cette cuisine est
de plus en plus parce qu'il a peut-être
moins d'appréhension et aussi aussi
d'évolution dans l'agroalimentaire qui
sont en train de se dire que même une
fois de plus qu'on arrête de faire des
cochonneries il ya moyenne de cuisine et
de préparer des plats cuisinés beaucoup
plus sainement qu'il nous est la
première scène et sans entre chimiques
les producteurs de fruits et légumes
mais pas seulement un au delà de plein
de produits pendant la période de
confinement ils se sont mis à vendre
directement au consommateur ou
particuliers ça va rester ça je pense
que des gens corrompus la possibilité
physique de pouvoir le faire mais jusque
use qui a été magnifique c'est que les
gens ont rencontré des hommes la légende
veut maraîchers il avait démarré chez
c'est lui qui fait les carottes ils ont
mis un visage et cette relation humaine
est super importante parce que c'est là
qu'on se rend compte que cette chaîne
alimentaire est importante aussi pour l'
équilibre nutritionnel mais aussi pour
l'équilibré humain on pensait qu'ils
sont vraiment prêts cette fois ci à
payer plus cher un peu plus cher
l'alimentation si elle est produite en
france est de qualité alors qu'andy de
bosschère oui c'est plus cher mais quand
vous prenez kilo de carottes
industrielle que vous allez payer 3
euros 50 qui vous prenez un kilo de
carottes chez le maraîcher que vous
allez payer avec 4 euros 50 c'est vrai
qu'il ya un euro c'est énorme mais sauf
quand vous g mené à la portion dans
l'assiette 6 di cule
c'est vrai que le coup le coût certes
est plus élevé mais après quand même il
ya le plaisir de cuisiner cuisine est un
produit quand on connaît le producteur
qu'il a préparé une jouissance à le
faire parce qu'on a un respect respect
d'apparat m'attire on a le visage las
besoin on a le visage face à nous de la
personne qui l'a fait est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va pouvoir re localiser
qu'est-ce qu'on devrait pouvoir produire
sur notre sol qu'on achète à l'étranger
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on prend pas
produire l'ensemble des matières
premières qu on a besoin pour nourrir
tout le peuple de france mais c'est
après on est comme des aberrations camp
quand on va chercher des fraises qui
nous arrive du chili quand on va chez
découvert que nous arrive de kenya
est-ce qu'on a un intérêt ça et après on
sait très bien que les produits de
saison sur tous les produits qui sont
optimales à la saison et les moins chers
est-ce qu'il faudra peut-être plus
attention à ça ça ne semble pas mettre
assez diversifié notre alimentation
durant toute l'année en respectant
régulièrement ses produits saisonniers
vous y croyez vous à ce mouvement de
relocalisation d'alimentation n'arriva
pas à 100% mais s'il ya une évolution de
10 15 20 % de plus tant mieux tant mieux
comme on dit toujours une ou deux
petites gouttes d'eau pour faire un
océan donc je pense qu'à une prise de
conscience générale et a pris aussi à
une prise de conscience doit de tout ce
qui est les hypermarchés les
supermarchés aussi eux aussi qu'ils s'y
mettent qu'ils se rendent compte que six
autres un rôle social à jouer avant de
penser qu'un rôle financier et je crois
cette crise voilà c'est ce qui s'est
passé durant ces trois mois vont servir
l'ensemble l'ensemble des tables
françaises et surtout dans l'ensemble
des tables c'était des tables du
particulier les états généraux de
l'alimentation avant la crise qui avait
réuni tous les acteurs de la filière de
la fourche à la fourchette et puis
savait pas vraiment porté ses fruits
vous vous attendez quoi des pouvoirs
publics sur cette question du bien
manger moi j'attends de zaki qui est
qu'ils aient si tu votes que la
population française à acheter français
sont tombés s'est passé du patriotisme
surtout pas de nationalisme peut-être
qu'il faut qu'il trouve une tva on l'a
on l'a soumis au ministre de
l'agriculture lui dira peut-être que
pour les produits français est-ce qu'on
peut pas faire une tva 1 % plutôt que
baisser la tva qu'on vole on achète
français parce qu il il faut pas que
quelque part on essaie de tirer le prix
d'achat descendre le prix d'achat ces
camions on va faire des miséreux en
donnant dans nos campagnes c'est pas le
but c'est simplement donner peut-être
que là il ya une part de tva qu'il faut
enlever de façon à ce que le projet
français se retrouvent à égalité avec le
produit qui arrive qui arrive d'autre
part dans votre sens de la planète alors
qu'est ce que vous dites pour terminer à
ceux qui nous regardent pour qu'il
retrouve le chemin de des restaurants et
du bien vivre à la française mais qu'on
est français que voilà qu'on est
français connaît la teinte qu'on aime la
vie et qu'il faut continuer à vivre
convives avant même si c'est vrai qu'ils
ont on ne reviendra donc pas de la même
façon parce que d'énormes salutaire
qu'on se mettre en place et c'est
peut-être bien aussi pour là pour tout
le monde alors soyons français restons
français vivent en français merci
cocorico merci beaucoup
[Musique]